years ago tupac had a song called only
god can judge me but today that's
changed to only the woke can judge you
if you let them because we've gone from
an era of innocent until proven guilty
today we're guilty until proven innocent
at least when it comes down to the
justice system there is a law and order
there are certain set of orders the
other day i got a speeding ticket guess
what i deserved it there was a number i
pressed that number it was going too
fast i got a ticket i got to pay the
fine but when it comes down to the awoke
system the woke justice system you're
walking on eggshells all the time nobody
knows what happens with the criteria
it's always changing you're getting
judged for what you said 20 years ago
and it's becoming a very very ugly time
to become anybody to have a voice and
you're getting canceled left and right
so today
we're going to take a deep down i've got
a lot of different things i want to get
into on the topic of cancer culture
[Music]
so my region quote from 2021 a president
was being interviewed on the topic of
cancer culture i'm not going to put his
picture up i'm going to show you the
silhouette and when i read you the quote
i want you to tell me which president
said this about cancel culture ready
let's read it together
a lot of dangers of cancer culture and
we're just going to be condemning people
all the time this idea of purity and
you're never compromised and you're
always politically woke and all that
stuff you should get over that quickly
the world is messy there are ambiguities
people who do really good stuff have
flaws so now can you guess which
president said that based on the
silhouette that i have with the hair
that's going to the right yes you're
right that quote i just read just by
barack obama yes barack obama this year
in 2021 about cancer culture even barack
obama is concerned and sees a threat
about cancer culture let me read you
what putin from russia said about cancer
culture yes this is putin putin said the
anti-racism agenda in the west was
dividing society as he compared cancer
culture warriors and liberal democracies
to the bolsheviks of russia's 1917
revolution the incessant emphasis on
race pushes people further apart whereas
the true fighters for civic rights tried
to eliminate those differences he
asserted noting that cancer culture is
nothing more than reverse discrimination
and teaching children that sexuality is
flexible is potentially crime against
humanity we look in amazement at the
processes underwent countries which have
been traditionally looked at a standard
bearers of progress that put about
america some people in the west believe
that an aggressive elimination of entire
pages from their own history reverse
discrimination against the majority in
the interest of a minority and the
demand to give up the traditional
notions of mother father family and even
gender they believe that all of these
are mild posts on the path towards
social renewal and by the way you just
heard from president obama and you just
are from putin these are people who have
two complete opposite philosophies they
don't agree with each other on many
philosophies but they agree on a topic
of cancer culture because everybody is
being affected by it and it's coming to
you as well by the way very very soon if
you're not too careful at the end of the
video i'm going to give you a formula on
how to make sure you never get canceled
so stick around till the end and i got a
few other quotes here as well but let's
get right into it first i want to unpack
our current justice system in america
today so let's kind of go through it
there's different kind of crimes you and
i can commit i'm going to put some of
them out there and i want you to tell me
which one of the crimes you think are
the worst from bottom all the way to the
worst but first let's look at our
justice system so here's how our current
justice system is based on different
crimes you can commit so here we go the
least serious this is somebody who has
infractions or violations generally a
fine only that's what i just did the
other day going too fast i got a ticket
i deserved it i have to pay 2 300 and
i'm going to get probably a strike on my
driving breaker my insurance probably
going to go up no problem i deserved it
number two
less serious a misdemeanor maybe you go
to jail maybe get probation maybe you
got a fine maybe you got a dui maybe you
were got caught smoking weed in a place
that's illegal so you get a misdemeanor
it's on your credit right let's go to
the next one which is the most serious
this is a felony all punishment options
are available execution prison probation
and fine now execution the death penalty
is based on some states but let's just
say most states have death penalty
option there for them some states have
death penalty options for them
that's what happens when you commit a
crime so you commit the crime
they say do you want an attorney you say
no you say yes but you have the option
then you go and give your case
lawyer says you know what you're not
guilty you can leave great it's black
and white there's a system for the most
part we have a justice system we're
trying to get it better but as broken as
the justice system is
the walks justice system is a million
times more broken so let's continue with
the justice system i'll give you a few
different crimes and you tell me uh on
your thermometer what is the worst crime
ready let's go through these together so
let's put these up on the screen for you
to look at we got your uh dealing
cocaine
you get a cow with a kilo of selling
cocaine another one treason you go out
there and
you have a
information on the inside against your
country but you give it to russia you
give it to china right your own insider
information you give it to russia you're
a military head and you give it to
russia okay next one is espionage okay
somebody from another country comes to
us is spying in our educational system
is spying on our companies is spying at
the government and they're giving out
information back so this is a spy from
another country working on the inside
treason is somebody on the inside giving
information to the enemy right let me
continue the other one is murder you
kill somebody accidental or intentional
let's just put it together you murder
somebody then you got rape then you got
child molestation then you got theft so
you got these seven that are right here
in what order do you say these crimes
are worse you know least worse to the
one that we need to give them the worst
kind of punishment what is it do you put
maybe theft at the bottom maybe you put
drug dealing at second to bottom maybe
sixth place seventh place maybe you go
treasonous six maybe you say espionage
espionage is fifth maybe you say
kidnapping is fifth maybe rape is third
maybe murder is second maybe child
molestation pedophilia is first that you
put on there so whatever your reasoning
may be
this is these are all crimes that are
committed somebody proved this is what
you did you go through the justice
system law and order protects of these
behaviors from happening so that allows
you and i to trust the system right
that's what this is
the screwed up thing about the cancer
culture system is there is no such thing
as out here
everybody is expected to walk on water
everybody so now when you look at the
justice system at least we know what the
crimes are right they have it you know
distribution of cocaine gets you this
many years rape gets you this many gears
first degree more murder second degree
accident you don't it's it's there it's
my state and it's known everybody knows
for cancer culture we don't know so what
is a crime in cancer culture let's go
through a few of them
if let's just say i say something that
offends you is that a deemable to cancel
me
let's just say if i uh
uh politically disagree with you is that
uh fair usage for you to come after me
and cancel me how about if i said
something 22 years ago that was
offensive which i'm sure i've said i'm
43 years old 22 years ago 21. i just got
out of the army most likely i've said it
is that proper for you to use that so
what what are the criterias to look for
is it a tweet from nine years ago
is it a certain word are we not allowed
to say the f word the c word the what is
it the n word the the
keep going all these words that are out
there that we're not supposed to say
when i was in the army i remember one
time i'm holding the m16
and i'm shooting to be a marksman and my
nose is against it guys looking at me he
says i've never seen a nose like that
before one of the guys sitting next to
me afterwards was a white guy from some
north dakota type of a city he said
where are you from iran i said yes he
says aren't people from iran terrorists
that's what he said to me in front of a
couple of my guys now you know what you
qualified that guy is he's a [ __ ] he's
an idiot should he be canceled no he's
ignorant that's what he is i've been
called camel jockey because i'm middle
eastern i was called fresh off the boat
i don't know by the way i'm not even
giving you this stuff to sympathize
please don't feel sorry for me i live a
very good life all i'm telling you is
people are going to offend you and i so
just because somebody offends us are we
going to go straight to the castle jail
let's put these people in jail is that
what we're going to be doing because the
justice system that we have
at least you can come out of it and you
can go through pro probation and then
you're free and we let them go right but
in the cancer culture they don't let you
back you're permanently canceled it's a
form of public execution if you think
about it it's character assassination
it's not even defamation of character
it's character assassination public
execution what can we do to get rid of
this guy it's the death penalty but
you're alive it's doing whatever they
can to ruin your name except your life
so this leads me to a thought about
cancellation so think about this
you got three things that they're going
to punish you to take away from you
which one of these three things you do
not want to give up like man i do not
want to lose xyz number one you lose all
your wealth they take all your money
away from me now you may be thinking
same fat i only got two thousand dollars
in a bank right now that's not a lot of
money to take away from me no i want you
to think you're worth 28 million bucks
they take every penny away from me every
house every car every bank account okay
they take away from me that's number one
number two
you lose your memory your identity you
don't know who you are you wake up the
next year like uh
what's my name who are my parents hey
babe i'm sorry why are you calling me
babe i don't know who you are like you
know you've seen this in movies what if
that happens you lose all your memory
number three
you lose your voice your influence your
silence you can never voice your opinion
ever again you can be on facebook you
can be on tick tock you can be on
twitter you can't be on twitter youtube
do nothing not no publisher nobody wants
to voice your opinion and give you that
platform which of those three can you
live with the rest of your life and
rebuild yourself up
is it money is it memory
or is it voice see that's what's going
on right now the challenge with it right
now is they're taking away all your
voice we don't want this person to say
anything because we don't agree with you
and that ought to concern you a little
bit as well this is not just about
people that are making money look we
know some of the names of people that
have been cancelled okay let me read
some of these guys and then some of them
that are potentially uh trying to be
canceled but they're part of the same
status but let's go through some of them
one of them is ellen degeneres another
one is kevin hart he was supposed to be
the host all of a sudden everybody wants
them to apologize for i think a tweet he
had nine or 11 years ago i don't even
know what the timeline was him and i
were talking about it at that time jk
rowling chris pratt pierce morgan who
you know he got canceled he had a great
show was funny on tv pissed a lot of
people off he made one comment about
merkel they used to date they cancelled
the guy in the next day he didn't do
anything else he just made a cup he's a
guy on tv supposed to give his opinions
gets canceled over that johnny depp gets
cancelled disney loves doing disney
world canceled the baby christy teigen
matt damon trump roseanne then we have
bill o'reilly we have matt lauer you
could even put louis ck in there you
know
dr seuss who is dead got cancelled they
took six or seven of his books off you
know and at one point it was the top
seven selling books was all his books
they're trying to cancel lincoln
i talked to lucian truscott who's
apparently the sixth grand uh son of
of uh
thomas jefferson we had the biggest
debate if you've never seen it he was
not too happy about it he wants to
remove his uncle's uh
statue because of what he did two three
hundred two hundred some years ago okay
who's gonna get cancelled like mlk
because he was a womanizer who's next
now i get r kelly that's a crime i get
harvey weinstein that's a crime but
there's a difference between canceling
because you disagree
versus canceling because somebody
committed a crime so another element of
cancer culture is just because i'm part
of a group i'm automatically being
judged for being part of that group like
i'm i'm middle eastern so there's all
these stereotypes i'm from iran there
are stereotypes i'm let's just say
wealthy they're stereotypes i'm
christian i'm this i'm that so let me
read this and you tell me how this feels
i bet one of these things is gonna
probably trigger some feelings and
emotions to you so let's go through it
there's two problems here let me read it
to you not everyone is racist but if you
are not all white people are white
supremacists but if you are not all
muslims are terrorists but a few are not
all black men are criminals but if you
are not all latinos cross the border
illegally but if you did not all
christians are bigots but if you are not
all theories are conspiracies but if you
are not all politicians are honest but a
few are not all immigrants are bad but a
few are not all police officers abuse
their power but if you do in everything
there's the few in the majority and
either the problem here is both because
one is
one is the fact that some people don't
like it if you say anything about their
group god forbid what do you mean you
know not all latinos that's offensive
what do you mean not all middle easterns
what do you mean not all this
and then but god forbid if you if they
do it it's okay if they do it to you so
hey we can call you a white supremac we
can call you racist but you can't say
that our community is you know such and
such no that's not how this thing works
i'm from iran believe me i'm a syrian
armenian my culture
has flaws both of them
we have flawed communities i understand
that i'm not naive to it but at the same
time i have a lot of pride in being
armenian assyrian
born in iran and made in america all of
those things mean a lot to me even
though i know the flaws this whole idea
of
white people are perfect all white
people are flawed or black people are
perfect or black people are flawed is
naive you have to understand that all of
us have challenges and i want to read
you a little bit more about what was
said here and then i'll give you the
final thoughts about what you need to do
to not get canceled here's what sharon
stone out of all people had to say about
cancer culture i think cancer culture is
the stupidest thing i've ever seen
happen i think when people say things
that they feel and mean and it's
offensive to you it's a brilliant
opportunity for everyone to learn and
grow and understand each other we all
come from different ages different
cultures different backgrounds different
things and have had different
experiences different traumas different
upbringings different parents different
religious backgrounds different
everything the basic instincts star
explained after hud asked if she thought
celebrities are afraid to have real
conversations here's what bill maher had
to say about cancer culture is this
really who we want to become a society
of phony avatars walking on eggshells
always looking over your shoulder by
getting ratted out for something that
actually has nothing to do with your
character or morals here's what johnny
depp had to say no one is safe but i
believe that if you are armed with the
truth then that's what you need now
here's what madonna had to say who never
got canceled after the comments she made
about
thinking about wanting to blow up the
white house when trump was in the white
house here's what she said about cancer
culture no one's allowed to speak their
mind right now no one's allowed to say
what they really think about things for
fear of being cancelled cancel culture
in cancer culture disturbing the peace
is probably an act of treason
interesting how we use the word treason
earlier and last but not least let's see
what kevin hart had to say about cancer
culture if people have done something
wrong the idea of canceling those people
and ending whatever courier or thing
they have if it's just over then what's
a teachable moment for them what it's
over and you can't do anything else for
the rest of your life because you made a
mistake what happened to the days of
making a mistake learning from a mistake
not doing that and educating others on
what not to do because of your mistake
isn't that parenting isn't that the
world of raising a kid how do you know
what to tell your kid to do or not to do
you have to be in a position of
experience to say don't touch that stove
because it's hot because you touched it
when it was hot i can't give you that
lesson if i don't have the experience so
it's interesting what kevin hart and all
these guys had to say about cancer
culture right here's what's interesting
do you know the other day i tweeted the
fine cancel culture guy responded back
and he said cancer culture is what
republicans use to get away with saying
whatever they want to say even though
they offend the other side do you
realize not a single person's quote i
used today was a republican not one
not one everyone's quote i used is on
the left
and they're majority from the hollywood
and the ones who had one point were okay
with trump getting cancelled some of
them not all the names they're the ones
that are being cancelled the wise ones
knew all along be very careful canceling
and silencing people here's my solution
to you on how to not get canceled in
today's times you ready don't say word
don't text a single word don't send an
email don't have an opinion have zero
feelings if you ever get angry don't
make a look don't give a smirk don't do
anything people ask you who did you vote
for you say i don't vote what do you
think about trump i don't have an
opinion what do you think about obama i
don't have an opinion what do you think
what happened in afghanistan i don't
have an opinion do you agree with aaron
rodgers what he said about him calling
joe rogan on ivermectin and he wants to
do that i don't have an opinion now
whatever you do just don't have an
opinion because god forbid if you do and
you say single word you'll be canceled
but do you really want to live that life
do you really want to live that life you
know how much i enjoy a good
conversation where people are having a
banter or who's the greatest basketball
player of all time you know how much i
enjoy the best banters of hey tell me
the best movie of all time the best love
story of all time the best rap song of
all time the best rapper of all time
these are all debates we're going to
disagree it's cool it's awesome we like
it you know someone i'm saying this is
okay with that so here's a few things
thoughts i have about cancer culture
okay
opposing ideas are okay clashing of
ideas are fine just because you disagree
with someone's opinion doesn't mean they
need to be canceled don't look for a
reason to cancel people it'll come back
and haunt you different values and
principles are a filtering system
walking on eggshells sucks there's a
difference between breaking the law and
offending you and last but not least
if you are part of the woke mob and you
feel
you are fully qualified to cancel
anybody and everybody you want i have a
test for you it's called a walk-in on
water test i want you to go to a local
swimming pool or the ocean or a lake or
anything you want to go to
and try to walk on that water if you
don't
you are officially disqualified from
canceling anybody so if you enjoy my
breakdown on cancer culture give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
and i want to hear your comments but i
got two other videos that i want you to
watch uh if you enjoyed this you'll
enjoy my sit down with lucian trust god
the great grandson
of thomas jefferson who wanted his
statue to be removed if you've never
seen that the intro alone is going to
want you to watch the entire interview
that's this one the other one is a i
love debates i think debate is a way of
us getting closer to the truth about a
year ago i was approached by alan
dershowitz and robert kennedy to do a
debate
on vaccine and one is saying the
government can mandate it the other
one's saying the government cannot
mandate it if you've not seen this one i
got a few million views click here to
watch that debate between two lawyers
going at it fascinating conversation
having said that have a good one
everybody take care bye
[Music]